donc mes chers amis merci mais non merci
mes chers amis ça fait plaisir de
commencer un samedi matin ordinaire avec
des adhérents si nombreux
je ne sais comment vous remercier de
votre confiance de votre amitié nous
déplacer comme ça samedi matin je
voudrais saluer tout particulièrement
valérie d'abord parce que je les
interrompu son excuse
et deuxièmement parce qu'elle est notre
tête de liste en île de france et que le
combat qu'elle mène en ile-de-france
d'un combat national
elle va nous amener la victoire nil de
france et on est tous derrière toi
moan et l'allemand
ce regret saluer eric ciotti elle
remercie parce que numérique tout en
charge des fédérations et je lui ai
demandé de revoir la quasi-totalité des
nominations secrétaires départementaux
parce que j'ai bien l'intention que les
républicains soient dynamiques au sommet
soit dynamique dans les candidats aux
régionales et soit dynamique dans les
départements j'ai demandé à eric qui a
fait ce travail qui est ici depuis ce
matin dès potron minet comme l'ont dit
et ça va impacter sur la vie des
nouveaux adhérents que vous êtes
puisque vous aurez à voter en janvier
pour les présidents de fédérations vous
allez voter et je ne veux pas d'accord
quand j'y joue par accor ce soit la
démocratie et que vous votiez dans vos
départements pour un président de
fédération ou une présidente dynamique
et autant les divisions me gêne autant
la compétition pour avoir l'honneur
diriger la fédération des républicains
au département ne me gêne pas c'est pas
silence dans les rangs et ce n'est pas
l'immobilisme
je dois également salué roger karoutchi
qui réveillait à la riposte
ça nous aide bien sa disponibilité son
talent parce que dès qu'il ya une
méchanceté à dire sur ceux qui nous
gouvernent
il y en a suffisamment qui se cachent
pour pour une fois il y en ait un qui il
va on le remercie je voudrais également
saluer philippe goujon qui est président
de la fédération de paris puis trois
nouvelles têtes parce que c'est très
très important qu'on renouvelle aussi et
je voudrais dire combien je suis content
de notre nouvelle porte parole lydia
guirous ce ya 29 ans qui porte une
parole vive
je sais que c'est une responsabilité sur
ses épaules mais pour l'instant elle
assume très bien
geoffroy didier que vous connaissez bien
les kamis bonheur de nos jeunes talents
qui travaillent 1 1 en clair j'espère
qu'un jour vous ferez tomber la ville de
nantes est aussi bon mes chers amis
avant de répondre à vos questions
je voudrais que vous compreniez ce qu'on
a voulu faire
au fond la seule question importante
comment suscitons de la confiance dans
un pays qui n'a plus confiance en
lui-même qui n'a plus confiance dans ses
dirigeants qui n'ont plus confiance dans
les institutions qui ne se fait plus
confiance et vous même qui est ici vous
dites est ce que cette fois-ci vonau des
soir vous même vous poser des questions
c'est pas rien d'avoir pris une carte
d'adhérent de nous avoir rejoints
c'est un choix qui implique et vous
n'avez pas envie d'être déçus et nous on
n'a pas envie de vous décevoir alors
on me dit maintenant tu as été président
de la république et leur maintenance du
président des républicains
je vois pas au nom de quoi ce serait
déchoir il s'agit d'entraîner des gens
au service du pays parce que si on est
l'un samedi matin 2 si vous avez payé
votre billet de train votre ticket
d'avion si vous êtes venus au lieu
d'être avec votre famille si vous êtes
ici c'est parce que vous croyez en
quelque chose qui est plus grand que
vous c'est la france sinon vous serez
pas venu que vous pouvez pas vous
résigner au spectacle terrifiant que
nous voyons tous les jours c'est ça qui
est en jeu eh bien nous on veut pas très
bien votre confiance et au fond
l'objectif que l'on a c'est terminé de
l'année aux alentours des 300 mille
adhérents pour arriver en 2010 est aux
alentours du demi million d'adhérents
c'est très important je vois bien que
c'est un enjeu très difficile en ce
moment on est à peu près 1000 nouveaux
adhérents par par jour tout ça pour me
relancer pas suffisant
faut qu'on aille il faut qu'on aille
plus loin on va déclencher notamment la
rentrée une grande campagne d'adhésions
et pour cela on a besoin que vous vendre
sentir respecté en tant qu'adhérent des
républicains et qu'on vous donne la
parole
on a fait une application valérie
beaucoup plus compétentes que moi
sur tous ces sujets ont marqué pas de
mal compte tenu du niveau assez basique
de mes compétences en la matière direct
citoyens je vous demande de télécharger
cette application mais je voyais les
chiffres ce matin n'est à 21000 22000
alors les équipes disent notamment
accède c'est formidable ça marche bien
tu ne sais jamais de 10% des nos
adhérents et par direct citoyens on va
vous interrogez vous interroger sur quoi
et ça c'est vraiment un sujet pour moi
absolument central et qui fera la
différence entre les républicains les
autres je veux que nous puissions parler
de tous les sujets à l'intérieur des
républicains je ne me laisserai pas
imposer la pensée unique qui voudrait
qu'on ne parle que des choses dans la
pensée unique voudrait que l'on puisse
évoquer pas les autres moi je veux qu
ici on est des débats sur les sujets qui
concernent les français pas sur les
sujets qui les concernent pas je prends
l'exemple j'avais demandé henri guaino
et à gérald darmanin une journée de
travail sur la question de l'islam et de
la république sur la question des
religions de la république
mon dieu mais qu'est-ce qu'on n'a pas
entendu comme torrent bêtises sur le
sujet qui peut me dire que cette
question ne se pose pas il ya une double
souffrance dans notre pays une double la
souffrance d'un certain nombre de nos
compatriotes musulmans qui n'en peuvent
plus dans un amalgame scandaleux à leur
endroit
après tout france est exactement comme
les autres des choix cultuelles et
culturelles qui sont les leurs ils n'en
peuvent plus d'être assimilés à des fous
à des barbares à des djihadistes
si on m'explique que ça n'existe pas
c'est qu'on vit pas dans le même pays
et que l'autre côté mes chers amis il ya
la peur d'une partie de la communauté
nationale face à une religion qu'elle
connaît moins et cette partie de la
communauté nationale se dit comment
va-t-on faire pour s'intégrer on veut
pas changer notre mode de vie
est ce que ces deux craintes quand je
les décris est ce que je décris une
réalité où je l'écris un fantasme d'une
réalité et tout le monde qu'on soit dans
la ruralité au qu'on soit sûr valérie
dans l'île de france pour importer
témoignages je voudrais qu'on puisse
débattre de ces questions là parce que
si on n'en débat pas qui va le faire le
front national avec un discours de haine
les socialistes avec une absence de
discours est encore chaud indulgence
matin si on n'en débat pas est notre
paris valérie c'est qu'on puisse en
débattre sans que personne ne se sente
exclu que chacun puisse se retrouver
dans notre position quelle que soit sa
couleur de peau quelle que soit son
origine quelle que soit sa culture
quelle que soit sa religion ou son
absence de religion on a débattu le
gouvernement fait des pressions
inadmissibles vous rendez compte ils
n'ont donc rien d'autre à faire que de
faire pression sur les dirigeants du
cfcm organise que j'ai créé et moi-même
pour qu'ils ne viennent pas j'ai entendu
le porte parole du gouvernement ne vient
pas de son nom
aucune idée de comment il s'appelle juin
monsieur à la télévision qui avait l'air
inquiet en sortant du conseil des
ministres je me dis pauvre homme qu'est
ce qui se passe
il a dû avoir une mauvaise nouvelle
c'est pourquoi ils inquiets après une
heure et demie en conseil des ministres
étaient inquiets à cause de moi
voilà ce porte parole du gouvernement
qui après une heure et demie en conseil
des ministres devait pas être bien
passionnant la discussion sort inquiète
parce que je suis là il est parti à
cause du chômage qui explose
il n'est pas inquiet à cause de dèche il
n'est pas inquiet du réchauffement
climatique
il est peint qui est de la sécurité il
n'est pas inquiet de l'immigration que
plus personne ne peut gérer
il est inquiet à cause de moi et vous
c'est pourquoi je m'inquiète parce que
j'ai demandé qu'on réfléchisse voilà la
reine on a tenu
je vais chercher on a fait cette journée
et finalement ça s'est très bien passé
on va continuer puisque nous allons
déjeuner avec le dirigeant du cfcm
d'ici à la fin du mois la question
centrale sur laquelle vous aurez à vous
prononcer est ce qu'il ya une loi de la
république
si elle voit la république est ce qu
elle doit s'appliquer
et s'il doit s'appliquer est-ce qu'elle
doit s'appliquer à tout le monde sait ça
je pense que dans les période
d'inquiétude et de troubles la règle
rassure l'absence de règles inquiète et
dans les règles
il ya les règles de laïcité mon ami eric
ciotti a posé un problème une question
dans une interview très intéressante
faut-il ou non remettre en cause ce
droit du sol s'agissant de l'immigration
cette question incontestablement c'est
une question qui peut se poser je ne
veux pas qu'on referme le débat avant
d'avoir mené le débat calmement
précisément dignement pour savoir ce que
nous allons décider et vous aurez à
trancher ce débat le moment venu
pouvez-vous doute la question c'est pas
les sujets qu'on prend c'est la manière
dont on epr dont on les considère nous
notre manière ça doit toujours être le
même nous devons penser que dans deux
ans la responsabilité de l'alternance
posera sur nos épaules
tout ce que nous dirons d'ici là nous le
ferons dans deux ans tout ce que nous
pourrons pas faire ne devons pas le dire
voilà très exactement lots furent serrés
rich dans le souci du rassemblement sans
aucune caricature mais sans lâcheté les
deux pêcheurs a mis les deux en même
temps
pas de caricature pas de l'acheter mais
je pourrais multiplier les exemples sur
le droit de propriété
j'ai vu les nouvelles décisions du
gouvernement en matière d'immobilier
est ce que les nouveaux accusés sont les
propriétaires et ce qu'elle fait d'être
propriétaire de son logement est un
problème pour le gouvernement le jour il
ya plus de propriétaires plus de
confiance comment le locataire pourra
t-il trouvé un appartement est ce que
quand on est propriétaire et qu'on nous
son appartement avec son locataire ne
paye pas
est ce qu'en tant que propriétaire en un
droit de l'expulser ou pas est-ce que le
sens de la vie c'est pas d'essayer de se
glisser dans l'échelle sociale pour que
ces enfants connaissent une vie
meilleure que la sienne
est ce que le but de la vie n'est pas
d'essayer d'avoir pour ses enfants et
pour ceux qu'on aime une meilleure vie
financé par son travail pas ses efforts
on en revient toujours au débat de 2012
avec monsieur hollande qui veut moins de
riches et moi qui veut moins de pauvres
l'axé central
mais nous sur des questions aussi
sensibles que les sf on peut avoir les
sf mais dans ce cas il faut sortir
d'europe
parce que si on reste en europe où les
personnes et les biens peuvent circuler
on ne peut pas être les seuls en europe
à avoir un impôt sur le patrimoine qui
fait fuir tout l'investissement et le
patrimoine dont nous aurions besoin pour
relancer l'économie de notre pays
c'est simple voilà l'objectif
voilà ce qu'on a envie de faire tous
ensemble ils terminaient par ça dans la
famille ou mes de rentrée il ne peut pas
y avoir d'ennemis entre nous ou
d'adversaires entre nous je je je veux
vous le compreniez soyez amis avec qui
vous voulez préféré qui vous voulez mais
dans la famille on peut avoir la
concurrence on ne peut pas avoir des des
stations et je ferai en sorte que les
élections régionales soit réservé des
élections présidentielles parce que
c'est déjà assez difficile pour nos
candidats et candidates comme valérie de
rassembler tout le monde pour gagner une
région de près de 12 millions
d'habitants
si en plus on s'entre déchirent pour une
élection qui aura lieu dans deux ans
comment peut-on gagner une élection que
la lionne en six mois
l'heure c'est un rassemblement derrière
nos candidats aux régionales qui ont une
rude partie parce que nous commun nous
avons nous battre à la fois sur la
droite puisque nous ne voulons pas du
front national et sur la gauche parce
que nous ne voulons pas des socialistes
si en plus on doit se battre en interne
ça n'a aucune signification
après viendra le temps des primaires on
les met en place tranquillement
chacun pourra faire valoir son talent et
ses chances d'ici là je ne veux pas
qu'on reconnaisse ce que l'on a connu
pendant les trois dernières années c'est
à dire un spectacle indigne de gens qui
s'entre déchirent alors qu'il ya la
souffrance en france nous n'avons pas le
droit de le déchirer à leur prédation
printemps france allait maintenant on va
répondre à vos questions et mes amis
vont me prêter main-forte aussi allez-y
c'est le jeu vous êtes discipline et
vous devez la main vous attendez le
micro à les y prenez ma parole et puis
moi je ne choisis pas aller mais non
mais dans le micro premier et 26 à
bombay larry faire
bonjour monsieur le président merci pour
cette invitation
c'est juste par rapport à l'immigration
qui a toujours été une question sensible
est aujourd'hui telle que ça se passe
avec la politique actuelle de la gauche
qui a du mal à gérer tout cela
ne pensez-vous pas peut-être qu'il
faudrait un deuxième chien vous remercie
vous venez d'où du sénégal non non non
paris de paris paris parfait oui parfait
merci non
c'est pas sorti l'an
je dois pas être assez aimable
certainement la question de la politique
d'immigration en france et en europe
sera l'une des plus central et des plus
difficiles à traiter
pourquoi l'afrique compte un milliard
d'habitants dans 30 ans le contrat 2
milliards 300 millions d'habitants le
nigeria dans 30 ans aura plus
d'habitants que les états unis
d'amérique
or l'afrique est à 12 kilomètres de
l'europe en d'étranges baltard et
quentin la méditerranée doit faire 800
km de large
si vous comparez avec l'atlantic eu 1000
km avec le pacifique 12000 km vous
comprenez les données du problème dire
qu'il n'ya pas de problème c'est une
folie voilà je vous dis les choses il ya
une question qui est absolument centrale
qui se posent et pour l'avenir de
l'afrique et pour l'avenir de l'europe
j'ajoute qu'un deuxième vague migratoire
qui celle-là n'est pas sud sud et sud
nord qui scella est-ouest par la turquie
et par la grèce deuxième remarque il
n'est pas question de porter un discours
de fermeture de la france je connais
l'histoire notre pays je connais ma
propre histoire et je sais parfaitement
que les civilisations meurent davantage
de la consanguinité que du métissage
mais entre l'ouverture raisonnable qui
enrichit notre culture notre
civilisation et l'europe est un
phénomène absolument incontrôlable comme
nous vivons aujourd'hui ya place me
semble-t-il pour une politique
déterminée
je suis résolument opposé à la
proposition de la commission sur les
quotas non pas parce que je suis contre
les quotas mais parce que ça consiste à
répartir le surcroît d'immigrés en
situation irrégulière entre les pays
européens sans se poser la seule
question qui doit se pose est celle de
la diminution du nombre
et irrégulière on peut faire des quotas
une fois qu'on a réduit l'entrée des
irréguliers pas avant je sais qu'il
s'agit d'êtres humains et nous sommes
tous bouleversés et c'est normal parce
que quelle que soit la couleur de peau
quand on vient mourir sur la
méditerranée ça doit tous nous
interpeller
mais c'est un peu comme la la maison ou
via une canalisation qui se déverse dans
la maison elle déverse dans la cuisine
et le type qui a réfléchi dit attention
on va répartir la fuite
on va mettre une partie de la
canalisation qui verra la fusion n'avait
fait aussi dans la salle à manger puis
dans le salon puis dans la chambre des
enfants sera la chambre des parents
dernier mais peut-être qu'on peut
réfléchir que le problème c'est pas de
répartir ces de réduire sinon qu'est-ce
que vous répartissez vous envoyer un
signal à tous les criminels du monde
entier qui utilisent la misère humaine
qu'il y aura plus de place en europe
c'est pas vrai il n'ya pas d'emplois n'y
a pas de logement il ya plus d'argent
donc la question mais pas de répartir
tout ce qui arrive
la question c'est comment est ton
l'afrique à se développer
et comment réduite dont le nombre
d'étrangers en situation irrégulière
troisième élément je ne crois pas la
réforme de schengen je n'y crois pas
parce que la machine est totalement
folle ça consiste à mettre une rustine
sur une jambe de bois
c'est la raison pour laquelle je dis
schengen doit être supprimée parce que
schengen a un péché nos pros sens moral
aux une faute originelle c'est qu'on a
fait schengen avant de demander aux
membres de schengen d'adopter la même
politique migratoire schengen c'est la
possibilité de circuler à l'intérieur
chacun a sa propre vie tes donc un
dumping migratoires à l'intérieur de
schengen je demande un nouveau schengen
qui nous permettent de contrôler nos
frontières et pourra dire à schengen
afin d'adhérer schengen chaque pays
devra avoir fait de l'effort d'adhérer à
la politique migratoire européenne comme
et j'ajoute à cela le problème de
l'immigration l'asile politique connaît
très bien
eric que la france soit ouverte aux
réfugiés politiques c'est la tradition
de la france et c'est l'honneur de la
france
mais quand on n'est pas réfugié
politique on ne doit pas bénéficier du
statut de réfugié politique
et donc quand vous pensez qu'en europe
on n'est même pas d'accord sur la liste
des pays sûrs c'est-à-dire des pays en
provenance desquels on ne peut pas voir
statut de réfugié politique
il ya problème du regroupement familial
sujet éminemment difficile il ya le
sujet encore plus difficile des mariages
parce que naturellement il s'agit pas
d'empêcher de z de c mais ce qui est la
plus belle chose du monde mais on parle
d'amour on parle pas d'acquisition de la
nationalité il ya le problème du droit
du sol qui a été levé entre autres par
eric tous ces sujets feront l'objet d'un
débat très approfondie de propositions
très précises sur lesquelles nous vous
demanderons un vote
j'ai été de ce point de vue dois je vous
le dire assez impressionné de ce qui
s'est passé en irlande pays catholique
référendum sur le mariage homosexuel
les irlandais répondu oui j'en tire quoi
comme conclusion j'en tire une
conclusion très simple chaque fois qu'on
donne la parole au peuple le peuple
prend la parole avec le sens de la
responsabilité que nous pas toujours les
élites qui voudraient confisquer la
parole du peuple
chaque fois qu'on refuse la parole au
peuple alors on puisse aller
responsabilité elle est là la réalité
elle est là parce qu'à partir de mots le
peuple choisi chacun doit respecter
cette décision
et c'est très intéressant et je vois des
éditoriaux des éditorialistes qui déjà
rare il faut pas poser la question ne
suis pas posé la question cela
présuppose ans que le peuple n'est pas
raisonnable mais moi je prie suppose que
ce sont les élites enfermé dans la
pensée unique qui sont déraisonnables et
qu'à chaque fois qu'on se tourne vers
les adhérents pour leur demander leur
avis alors à ce moment là ils se sentent
respectés et la vie qu'ils expriment
c'est un avis responsable et modestement
n'a eu cette question sur le nom quand
j'ai réfléchi au nom de notre nouvelle
formation politique
je savais que l'immobilisme était une
majorité dans notre mouvement et
pourtant j'ai choisi de vous demander la
parole vous donner la parole j'étais 84%
à voter pour le non et républicains qui
aurait dit cela
qui aurait parié sur ça eh bien je crois
qu'il faut qu'on rentre de plus en plus
dans la stratégie qui consiste à vous
donner la parole pour rétablir les bases
de la confiance entre vous et les
institutions de la république
au fond ça sera ça la marque de fabrique
des républicains quand on est membre des
républicains on vous donne ma parole
vous l'apprenez des choix sont faits et
ces choix sont ceux qui vous représente
et non pas ceux d'une pensée qui vous
passent au dessus de la tête
parce que je suis persuadé qu'une
majorité de nos concitoyens en ont plus
qu'assez d'entendre à longueur de
télévision de radios et de journaux des
idées dans lesquelles ils ne se
reconnaissent pas voilà l'enjeu entre
nous l'immigration est
cl